Des télescopes au Grand collisionneur de hadrons,
chaque nouvel outil scientifique a toujours revisité les questions
que nous, en tant que scientifiques
et esprits curieux, pouvons raisonnablement poser.
Le calcul haute performance, ou HPC,
a rejoint cette liste d'élite dans les années soixante. Aujourd'hui,
les ordinateurs quantiques frappent à la même porte.
Bienvenue, je m'appelle is conducive to coffee
et je suis ingénieur logiciel ici chez IBM Quantum.
Dans ce cours, nous visons à enseigner aux étudiants
et aux professionnels comment l'informatique quantique va bientôt
fonctionner en collaboration avec les infrastructures HPC
pour fournir des résultats de calcul.
Tu apprendras comment le quantique
et les ordinateurs classiques communiquent et échangent des données,
comment écrire des programmes qui exploitent les deux types de matériel,
et comment cette intégration ouvre des applications que l'on ne peut pas résoudre aujourd'hui.
Tu acquérras une expérience pratique avec du vrai matériel quantique
et des clusters de calcul haute performance classiques,
en exécutant des jobs quantiques en parallèle avec des charges de travail HPC traditionnelles,
et tu sauras interpréter les résultats avec confiance,
et identifier les endroits où l'accélération quantique
pourrait vraiment aider les calculs,
et là où elle n'aide pas. Surtout, tu comprendras
vers où l'avenir de l'informatique se dirige
et la feuille de route qui nous y amènera. Nous pensons que
ce cours est à la fois important
et d'actualité, et nous croyons que
la combinaison de ces technologies sera essentielle
pour atteindre l'avantage computationnel.
Cela pourrait avoir des impacts à grande portée dans des secteurs comme
la chimie, en permettant potentiellement
une conception de médicaments plus rapide et la recherche en matériaux,
dans la finance,
pour des modèles de risque plus intelligents
et la détection de fraude, dans l'intelligence artificielle et le machine learning
pour l'optimisation de modèles. Dans ce cours,
nous allons plonger en profondeur dans les ressources informatiques,
les modèles de programmation et les algorithmes quantiques.
Alors bienvenue et prépare-toi,
on a beaucoup à voir !